wir machen ein spiel ich ziehe ein
zettel ihr und philipp muss raten was
draufsteht ich muss gewinnen sind die
haare ok jahre sind wunder wunderschön
wieso muss ich eigentlich raten weil die
klinker bis das wissen wir doch alle
wir sollten sie auch sagen dass es sich
überhaupt der doktor inhalt genau dein
lieblings autohaus hermann nein älter
schon tot
heinrich böll die zeit ist nicht ganz
falsch lange mein lieblingsautor als ich
16 war hermann hätte
bravo jetzt bist du dran okay mein
lieblingsautor von dir schon wieder
frank schätzing ja ich hab nur
lieblingsautor das ist könnte einer
deiner favoriten sein was man nähe aber
heinrich von kleist naja von tonne
nein aber die zeit ist ja danke ich sehr
schönes spiel ja da fühlt man sich
plötzlich so klug und gebildet
der klassische autor der deutschen
sprache schlechthin
ich bin dran hat zwei romane geschrieben
aber einer davon ist bekannt geworden
und wurde auch verfilmt und danach hat
er nie wieder geschrieben fast ein
phantom es gibt nur glaube ich ein oder
zwei fotos von ihm offizielle also
welche sprache bist du jetzt hannibal
lecter immer nein aber ein sehr
bekannter bestseller-autor deutsch lebt
in münchen hatten sohn botho strauß nein
simon strauß sohn ein bestseller autor
findet stehen dem die amis kennen meine
güte was soll ich noch alles sagen
renault patrick süßkind ja es gibt nur
zwei fotos von patrick süskind ja okay
dann kenne ich beide vielleicht jetzt
auch drei offizielle jetzt kommt das
löst jurist schreibt bücher ging's ja
die dinger weiß schon der mensch ging
das schnell großartig aber was wo sich
der preis der preis es heißt genau ein
buch